if you want to get around if you want to
drive a car you want to get on a plane
you need oil it has been the foundation
of the 20th century economy once
considered impossible American energy
independence has become a reality and
for better or for worse it's all thanks
to fracking the spoils of which have
spurred what's commonly called the shale
revolution it is almost impossible to
overstate the transformational effect
that fracking had on US oil and natural
gas production it became this rallying
cry that the shale boom was really gonna
transform the u.s. into a dominant
energy player it changed everything
really the u.s. went from producing
about 5 million barrels of oil a day in
2008 up to 13 million barrels of oil
just this last march it was this what we
thought at the time was going to be this
great American success story except for
one problem the numbers never added up
for every dollar they brought in they'd
be spending a dollar ten or dollar 20 or
dollar 50 this has always been the
Achilles heel of the business the oil
sector always needs to be very careful
about the level of investment it makes
and the cash returns to investors the
investment community did not finance the
shale revolution out of the goodness of
their hearts I think they liked the idea
of US energy independence but they
wanted returns and for the most part
they haven't come there has never been a
better decade for growing US oil and gas
production and yet what was the
worst-performing sector in the sp500
energy that tells you a lot about this
sector 26 US oil and gas producers have
filed for bankruptcy this year this is
the story of how shale went from
revolution to a bottomless money pit
[Music]
in order to understand how much shale
changed the energy game you have to go
back a half century or so about 50 years
America has been way short of oil and
gas having to import these vital fossil
fuels that are essential to the running
of the economy and everyone believed
that we would be importing almost all of
our oil requirements for the foreseeable
future really that that shaped American
economics for decades and we had the the
Arab oil embargo in the 70s you've had
Wars event recessions all driven by
shortages of oil and gas from 1970 until
2000 the u.s. imported most of its oil
from Saudi Arabia and Russia
companies like Exxon and Chevron were
exploring drilling all over the world in
places like the Arctic and Africa
[Music]
but fracking changed everything when we
talk about fracking we basically talk
about the combination of two
technologies horizontal drilling and
hydraulic fracturing and when they come
together it allows oil producers to get
oil and gas out of very very dense shale
rock buried deep beneath the earth and
it really unlocked huge huge resources
of oil and gas
it was briefly profitable as a gas game
but very quickly the problem with any
kind of commodity industry is supply and
demand so natural gas fracking unleashed
such a plethora of supply the price
plummeted and it's never recovered after
shooting itself in the foot by flooding
the gas market the fracking business
managed to pivot to oil and what we find
is that all the lessons that were
learned in natural gas could be applied
just as easily to deposits of oil
because it's essentially the same
process a lot of people thought this was
hocus-pocus it was never gonna work and
but there were there were a few
companies who decided to try it just in
case
lo and behold it works
Texas tea so enormous amounts of money
flooded into the sector and you had lots
of companies took the money and we're
not drilling it was a perfect storm near
zero interest rates prompted by the
financial crisis mixed with a seemingly
endless demand for oil and gas its
sky-high prices gave way to a veritable
feeding frenzy of hungry investors on
Wall Street this made it very easy for
small independent shell companies to get
started
you could really just lease up land and
if you had partners and you know even
just a small amount of investment you
could just try to figure out where the
good rock was and that meant that
sometimes you lost and sometimes you won
but when you won you won big for years
the big majors didn't want anything to
do with it they stayed out of it so it
really was almost like modern-day
wildcatting and people made fortunes
[Music]
throughout American history oil has
always attracted the rebellious type and
fracking was no different back then and
today these guys were called wildcatters
in the movies you see those pictures of
the the rugged Texas oil wildcatter
standing in front of some spewing well
wildcatter was basically someone who
took what was considered like a small
amount of money at the time and went out
and leased up a bunch of acreage and
poked holes in the ground to try to
figure out where the oil was and no one
personified the modern-day shale
wildcatter better than Aubrey McClendon
we might have brought a way for America
and the world to be able to increasingly
say no to OPEC Aubrey McClendon was the
founder and CEO of a company called
Chesapeake Energy he's a fascinating
character just larger-than-life he was
one of the first to appreciate the scale
of America's shale gas reserves if
there's an old maxim in the oil business
drill baby drill
that was Audrey to a tee if you gave him
money if you had access to money any
money no matter how hard he had to
scrounge to find it he was going to go
drill a well with McClendon as Shales
mascot companies like Chesapeake and a
slew of other startups rode a wave of
glory and shale was hailed as the next
great American success story
so 2010 to 2014 we're really the glory
days of shale this is this is when you
had everything going right you had oil
prices that's a $100 a barrel
you had Wall Street throwing money at
these companies you had exploration
being very successful finding all these
new areas all these new basins the idea
that you could take something that was
in your own backyard
and make your country this big global
player is a really romantic one and I
think a lot of people believed in that
and so the oil flowed lots of it so much
that America's standing actually
reversed from a net importer to a net
exporter of oil and for the wildcatters
and consumers alike it was a remarkable
transformation but what no one seemed to
want to admit is that shale extraction
is incredibly expensive in a shale well
is very different from a traditional oil
wealth well the conventional well once
you've drilled it if you're lucky enough
to hit natural gas or oil the well
generally continues to produce for a
long long time
shale wells by nature explode and this
flight spew of production and it's like
if you take a champagne bottle and you
shake it you're gonna get bubbles
flowing over
but the decline that happens after that
initial burst of production you can see
a shell well lose 70% of production
after its first year I mean it's pretty
staggering as a shell producer you're
constantly fighting this enormous
decline right you need to constantly be
drilling new wells new wells new wells
new wells which is more money more money
more money if you think about the
mindset of dot-com companies back in the
day it was get market share just grow
grow grow claim the market then it's all
yours then you're gonna be able to
produce profits and Aubrey McClendon
mindset and the mindset of many in the
shale industry was much the same way and
while investors kept pouring in new
money
shale executives were raking in huge
salaries even as their companies were
sinking executives were paid based on
production growth not on profits and if
you reward an executive to grow then
growth is what they're going to do tell
an oil guy that not only does he have
money to go drill but you're gonna pay
him if he can go produce more oil he's
gonna go produce all the oil he possibly
can you can't slow down or your company
shrinks but if you keep growing you're
just constantly putting pash in the
garage to drill new wells and eventually
investors are gonna say wait a second I
need you to stop drilling wells if
you're not gonna be able to give me my
money back
over the last decade an estimated 340
billion dollars has been spent on US
fracking it's what everyone refers to as
the treadmill the problem of course is
when the treadmill stops or when you are
forced to get off the treadmill
how low could oil go then referred to
the Thanksgiving Day Massacre there is
growing concern among some members of
OPEC that shale was eating their lunch
because you had this enormous growth in
the sector Saudi Arabia
there's thinking a bigger picture to
protect the oil price now we have to not
cut because otherwise shell all will get
the advantage the entire shale business
model was predicated on high oil prices
any serious drop and it all comes
crashing down who's winning
consumers who's losing well obviously
producers but maybe people have lent to
producers need to be a little bit more
worried than perhaps they have picked us
frackers who had been promising they
could make money suddenly it was clear
they couldn't make money and the capital
that going into the industry started to
dry up well over a hundred companies
ended up declaring bankruptcy and people
said the shale revolution is over but
since when has a slew of bankruptcies in
a highly volatile market stopped any
self-respecting entrepreneur there was
still a lot of people willing to invest
billions of dollars in shale a big
reason why investors remained interested
in shale was the rediscovery of a huge
reserve in Texas called the Permian
Basin the hype around this region became
known as per mania and so even though
there was this downturn the the music
really didn't stop playing guys like
Aubrey McClendon used pro mania to
continually sell the shale story even as
the price per barrel made the model
totally unsustainable and fighting back
the cloud over shale was going to prove
as futile as trying to change the
direction of the wind the reckoning came
in 2016 with McClendon's death
the Oklahoma City Police Department
responded to a fatality accident
involving mr. Aubrey McClendon the
government had been investigating him on
price-fixing charges and they indicted
him in the spring of 2016 and the day
after he was indicted he went out in his
SUV and hit a bridge at top speed and
was killed his death was almost like the
punctuation mark underscoring what was
supposedly the end of the shale
revolution but it came back and the main
reason it came back is because we were
still in the super low interest rate
environment investors didn't have
anywhere else to put their money and so
it came roaring back oil prices continue
to rise steadily and shale execs drilled
harder than ever praying for increasing
oil prices in promising returns two
anxious investors 2020 was supposed to
be the year where the top 2025 players
in the independent US oil industry were
supposed to an aggregate turn cashflow
positive for the first time but of
course that didn't happen in March of
2020 Russia triggered an oil war with
Saudi Arabia effectively killing an
important OPEC deal cratering global oil
prices and as if that wasn't enough the
corona virus pandemic is triggering
fears of a global recession crude oil
drops below $30 a barrel the impact and
the oil is disproportionate oil prices
crashed and everything changed
within weeks you started seeing the
impacts of the corona virus and the
subsequent lockdowns having effect on
oil demand and unlike the last downturn
this one was really triggered by a
complete collapse and demand global
demand for oil was already low since
governments imposed widespread lock
downs and Airlines grounded flights
because of a disease there were lots of
passive investors people who own all
futures but have zero interest in taking
delivery of a physical barrel
of crude oil suddenly realizing that
they were going to be on the hook for
taking delivery of crude oil I think
what everyone will remember for many
years to come
is the day oil prices fell to negative
37 dollars a barrel since then
oil prices have bounced back but the
shale wildcatters have not some of the
quickest to rise have already fallen
including McClellan's whiteknight
Chesapeake Energy which filed for
bankruptcy in June of 2020 are we almost
through this bankruptcy cycle in the
distressed oil and gas patch we are not
for a lot of these guys it was going to
happen anyway and this really just
accelerated it Natali's is still coming
in but the number of jobs lost in the
collapse and Mishael business is going
to be crushing fracking actually
provided some four million jobs in the
decade since the financial crisis it's a
sudden demise perhaps a hint of things
to come for the beleaguered shale oil
industry yet amidst this collapse shale
execs have been taking home huge bonuses
well gas executives have typically made
well over 100 percent of their target
bonuses even as their returns or stock
performance has been in the negatives
and now that the bubble is burst many
environmentalists have seized on these
failures to make their case against
shale you actually have a coming
together almost of environmentalists and
investors to say just keep the oil in
the ground because there is too much of
it
environmentalists were delighted by any
reports that fracking wasn't financially
viable because it appeared to be support
for their claim that this industry
needed to go away the lack of profits in
the fracking industry means that it's
all of us it's taxpayers who are going
to be stuck with the cleanup cost with
what it's done to our water supply with
what it's done to our environment
[Music]
the lure of American dominance in the
energy sector remains strong and despite
the shale revolutions faulty business
model and unresolved environmental
concerns the powerful desire to extract
oceans of oil that lay beneath our feet
will likely never relent fracking has
come back from the dead several times I
wouldn't count the industry out I don't
know that we'll ever see the heyday that
we did in the last few years again but I
think it's too soon to say that fracking
is going away
[Music]